who should you want to share your last
lesson loud you want to show your
definition of a circle Kate thank you
would you like to share your definition
of a circle with all of us who use the
word round ends up I think a lot of
people use the word round which you know
I didn't say any words are off-limits
thank your hands down I use the word
circular a circle is a shape that is
perfectly circular that's okay go ahead
just give us your definition okay I
guess so
so I'll come back to I'll come back to a
definition a second but Ellen raises a
great point which is that like what is a
radius and the radius is a feature of a
circle remember this aliens never seen a
circle before right so it starts to be
like wait so what is this shape because
you guys have known that circles for so
long there's such a common shape in the
world that's like well I don't know what
language to use I like the definition
though it's very well I'm going to come
back to it
Ryan's yours different yeah go ahead
wait hold on
a constant curve that follows itself
around until it until it what I don't me
to get follows one one coin one what are
you my constant okay all right so so you
can see it's like I would use words but
it's like oh we have all this meaning in
their region like but I don't know
constant means all of different things
doesn't it could I was about to draw
this I just I mean you know you get the
idea of like
July by an ego consciousness it's sort
of depending on what you understand
constant to me it's a curve it follows
are all very enjoyed anyway does any
want to have one more step yeah good
okay how many people say interaction
asymmetry really yeah okay very good
thank you hear that okay I'm going to
give you my definition which arm again
just like Ellen we've always pointed out
before all definitions are going to have
some trouble because they're going to
refer to ideas that is like well but do
you know what these are so I've got a
set of actions here we're going to draw
a circle on top of this underneath it
let's draw or let's write rather this
definition okay a circle is excuse me
the set of points or and I'm going to
use a fancy word here which maybe
haven't seen before
but as soon as you see I think you will
know what it means the word itself tells
you what it means the set of points all
equidistant from a central point
okay now this shares some of the
characteristics or the definitions I saw
around but it's also quite different
isn't it I don't think I did anyone talk
about points at all didn't only use the
word point in a different definition in
anyway yeah a couple of character yeah I
did hear this equidistant what I mean
what do you think of me same distance so
in some ways this is what Ryan was
talking about that the consonant curve
but there's just a slightly more fancy
technical way of saying it and you have
to say it's all the same distance from
somewhere right which is the center but
maybe you don't know what the center is
you know in a circle before so I said a
central point it's a point just like the
others but it's in the middle okay now
what I'd like you to do is put a
Cartesian plane on top of your circle
right in the middle okay so let's go
look tell you I did
you're set square for we shuffled around
the middle it didn't quite stay hey nice
one really good yeah school pages are
good i read if the string is in and not
patients will untie it
patients can do lots of things have you
ever tried it
very nice very nice
okay um I was just looking of course you
can what you do all right
can I ask you now regardless of whether
you've drawn a circle or not you'll have
the rest of person to go ahead and keep
playing can I ask you to put your pens
down with and have a look up with me
because we need to think together and I
don't know about you I'm terrible
multitasking and they're thinking and
drawing at the same time I think we're
good badly so pop your pens down
out of your handset squares out of your
hands and I want you to order have your
eyes fixed here okay there's still
strictly speaking in your hand so yeah
thank you okay so eventually you will
have something that looks somewhat like
this your circle probably actually look
a bit better than mine mine's a bit
potato ish I think I think that's the
adjective choice right now here's only
going to try and do the four graphs that
we had a look at this morning when we
reviewed right they're all in terms of
the nine terms of words like this
they're in terms of symbols like this
right so what we want to try and do is
move toward an understanding of this
shape that is not just this but is also
this now how will we do it okay so here
is an example circle I'll ask you to
also draw the Cartesian plane solid
right in the center okay so that means
that this central point you know where
it is what are the coordinates of the
central point zero zero so in a minute
you're going to label that on but I want
you to be focused first
okay so pen should still be out of hand
is that you - thank you now not only do
we know that and then do something a bit
weird I'm going to pick a random point
on the circumference of the circle and
this really could be any point okay so
that means if it can be any point I
can't tell you the number of the
coordinates right because the numbers
can change if it can really be any point
if only I had a branch of math that
deals in numbers when they can be
different and they can change away it's
algebra so here's what I'm going to do
instead of naming the coordinates by a
number because the point is that the
coordinates can change I'm just going to
call the x coordinate X and I'm just
going to call the y coordinate one I
really could call them anything I like I
call them P and Q or M and N or or Ryan
and thieves component two but this
Layana the X is an X and the wise one